[Musik]
goviral namen von luca guadagnino ist
für mich wirklich eine der bühne des
jahres für mich so unerwartet kam ich
jetzt mal wieder davon gehört er gibt
schon im vergangenen jahr bei der
berlinale den verpasst sondern wieder in
amerika und alle waren begeistert
anderem erzählt unsere und hier läuft er
jetzt nun endlich an professor für die
einladung aber gern meine güte ist
größer als die auf dem foto wird am
beispiel einen austausch studenten er
dort für den sommer über arbeitet an
seiner doktorarbeit offensichtlich und
er kommt dort an eigentlich ein bisschen
wie heraus also alle sind sofort
eingebunden in ein umfassendes begehren
was gar nicht jetzt bedeutet dass sie
geht ins bett wollen oder so alle er ist
einfach da und erinnert jeden seinen
eigenen körper weil er selber diese
körperlichkeit so selbstverständlich
lebt alle sind völlig hingerissen man
als zuschauer ist man es auch muss man
sagen ihm durchaus ebenbürtig mindestens
ist der sohn des hauses in die
liebesszene zwischen den beiden gehört
so man sie überhaupt sieht die kamera
ist dann durchaus auch diskret er gehört
zum schönsten was ich in diesem register
jetzt im kino gesehen habe liebesszenen
sexszenen sind ja immer außerordentlich
problematisch sind häufig peinlich gehen
in die hose und hier ist das ganz
wunderbar gelöst
das klingt wie alles hast du's abgewandt
ja ich hab ein bisschen abgeändert wieso
ich habe es in etwa wie liszt gespielt
wenn er bachs version interpretiert
hätte spiel das noch
ich bin eigentlich sehr dagegen zu sagen
dieses ist schwules kino
deswegen sage ich es ist so schön zu
sehen in die grenzen fließend
also kein homosexueller film obwohl eine
homosexuelle liebesgeschichte darin
vorkommen alle es kommen auch
heterosexuelle liebesgeschichten oder
kleine liebesaffären daran vor und
insofern nein ich würde auf keinen fall
das jetzt im schwulen kino so zu
schlagen und das gleich wieder
reduzieren und gleich wieder in eine
schublade tun ist das für mich wirklich
einer der schönsten filme auf der
schönsten liebesfilme der letzten zeit
gregor
haye konnte
es im film für träume so ein bisschen
weil natürlich auch die leidenschaft
meines norditalien es ist hochsommer
es spielt unter archäologen also es ist
schon ein großes quantum schönheit dabei
und dazu eben dieses wetter ich denke
jeder der schönheit liegt wenn ich an
jeder der schönheit liegt sollte mich im
namen nicht
[Musik]